which brands are doing it well I will
say that chipotle somebody that we don't
work with that I could see from the
outside that has made a huge commitment
to Social and culture is doing a nice
job from my filter people that are
allocating all their money to Brand work
that's not being seen or programmatic
digital banner ads that no one's
consuming it's hard for you to do it
well what Chipotle's done well is
they've made an actual commitment to
social media creative I think Wendy's
talking about a couple qsrs and think
about those companies they can see the
results on the day right they have
stores and so DDC Brands qsrs but some
of these consumer package good brands
car brands Automotive like these big big
Brands they continue to buy into Don
Draper and he's been dead for a long
time